ein kleiner Warnhinweis in eigener Sache
was ihr nämlich in dieser Ausgabe
vielleicht vermissen werdet das ist Toni
die ja mit Mirko ein so hervorragendes
Doppel bildet dass ich da eigentlich gar
nicht zwischenstehen möchte außer sie
ist krank und dieser Fall ist
eingetreten bei dieser Ausgabe mein Name
ist Stefan Netzeband und ich bin der der
ganz oft die Skripte für diesen Podcast
schreibt und in diesem Notfall muss ich
also jetzt quasi selber mal ins Mikro
ich kann schon vorweg das eine sagen mir
hat Spaß gemacht ich hoffe euch auch wie
viel Minuten
[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
Ausgabe von Tatort Deutschland dem
täglichen truecrime Podcast von Bild
mein Name ist Mirko Kasimir und bei mir
im Studio ist Stefan Netzeband hallo
Stefan hallo Mirko hallo liebe
Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer Stefan was
würdest du sagen wenn ich dir erzählen
würde dass Wolfgang Amadeus Mozart mit
einem Gift ermordet wurde dass aus der
Spucke von Männern hergestellt wurde die
man kopfüber aufgehängt und dann an den
Fußsohlen zu Tode gekitzelt hat mir ich
würde sagen von den Tabletten die Du
genommen hast möchte ich auch eine
abhaben also nein ich würde sagen dass
du in einem Podcast über wahre
Verbrechen wahrscheinlich falsch bist
und vielleicht eher einen einen Märchen
Podcast machen solltest okay gute
Antwort aber ist doch eine tolle
Geschichte oder auf jeden und natürlich
hättest Du damit nicht angefangen wenn
es nicht doch irgendeinen wahren Kern
daran gäbe oder ja einen wahren Kern und
ein wahres Verbrechen denn darum geht es
hier ja dann lass uns jetzt am besten
mal anfangen auf geht's weiter zurück in
die Vergangenheit in die 50er Jahre des
17 jahrhunderts nach Rom im Mai 1656
kommt die Pest in den Kirchenstaat ein
infizierter Seemann auf einem Schiff aus
Genua hat sie eingeschleppt der Schwarze
Tod wütet unter Armen und Reichen unter
frommen und Sündern er nimmt wen er
kriegen kann sicher kennt ihr dieses
gruselige Bild eines mittelalterlichen
pestoktors mit langer Schnabelmaske
schwarzem Umhang und schwarzem Hut das
Symbol für die berüchtigste Seuche ihrer
Zeit tatsächlich bezieht es sich direkt
auf die Pest der Epidemie in Rom als
Kind fand ich das super gruselig jetzt
eigentlich auch noch obwohl ich später
erfahren habe das muss ich dazu erzählen
dass man das nicht ganz ernst nehmen
darf das Bild schuf ein Mann namens Paul
Fürst in Nürnberg nämlich nachzeichnen
die ihm zugesandt wurden und es war
vermutlich satirisch gemeint so was hat
also damals auch schon gegeben in der
Beschreibung des Bildes heißt es unter
anderem dass der Doktor Schnabel nichts
anderes tut als Menschen Angst
einzujagen und Geld von den Toten und
Sterbenden zu nehmen was aber stimmt ist
dass insbesondere in Rom während dieser
Epidemie strenge Vorschriften erlassen
und mit eiserner Hand durchgesetzt
werden dazu gehört auch Schutzkleidung
für Ärzte Brille Handschuhe und eine
Maske nur sah die in Wirklichkeit wohl
nicht ganz so spektakulär wie auf dem
berühmten Bild aus aber das Bild hat
sich tief in unserer Kultur eingebrannt
und erschreckt uns seit fast 500 Jahren
Stefan ich kann dir aus eigenem Erleben
versichern dass du nicht der einzige
bist der davon als Kind Albträume hatte
du also auch Mirko ja ich würde sagen
Generationen von Kindern also wie auch
immer diese peststrukturen in Rom
wirklich ausgesehen haben die
Schutzkleidung wirkt weil sie den
direkten Hautkontakt mit den Kranken
verhindert und gleichzeitig fängt Papst
Alexander der siebte damals ja ein
Lockdown würde man das heute nennen die
Grenzen werden geschlossen infizierte
und Verdachtsfälle kommen in Quarantäne
und hätte es damals schon Smartphones
gegeben dann hätte sicher auch jemand
eine schlecht funktionierende pest-app
programmiert und dem Start für viel zu
viel Geld verkauft aber ich merke schon
ich schweife ab die Maßnahmen sind
jedenfalls erfolgreich in Rom sterben im
Zuge dieser Epidemie zwar immerhin 9.500
Menschen an der Pest aber im Rest
Italiens schätzt man die Zahl der Opfer
in den Jahren 1656 57 auf eine Million
aber in Rom tötet nicht nur die Pest
noch eine Epidemie fördert Opfer um
Opfer und diese ist noch viel
beunruhigender dazu mindest für die
Oberschicht im Kirchenstaat dann wurde
der schwarze tot unterschiedlos
zuschlägt tötet
aquatophaner ausschließlich Männer und
oft sind sie reich und mächtig
[Musik]
das Wasser der Tofana das Elixier des
Todes
die ersten Berichte erreichen den Papst
aus den beichtkabinen der heiligen Stadt
Priester brechen das Beichtgeheimnis um
unvorstellbare Verbrechen offen zu legen
Verbrechen gegen die göttliche Ordnung
nach der der Mann dazu bestimmt ist über
das Weib zu herrschen Frauen sind
nämlich in der Ober- und Mittelschicht
reine Verfügungsmasse man verheiratet
sie minderjährig um wirtschaftliche oder
politische Allianzen zu schmieden und in
der Ehe sind sie oft zu Gehorsam
verpflichtet rechtlos und ohne Zugriff
auf das Vermögen ihren oft gewalttätigen
Ehemännern auf gedei und Verderben
ausgeliefert der berühmte goldene Käfig
also und
aquatopaner scheint so mancher wie der
Schlüssel um genau diesen Käfig zu
entkommen ein Geruch und geschmackloses
Gift man gebe einige Tropfen ins Essen
des ungeliebten Garten und nur wenige
Wochen oder Monate später ist die Ehe
auf die einzig legal mögliche und
denkbare gottesfürchtige Weise bis das
der Tod euch scheidet geschieden und auf
den Straßen von Rom tratschen die Weiber
und die verängstigten Kerle über all die
jungen Witwen die neuerdings zu
vermelden sind für die Männer beginnt
alles mit ein bisschen Unwohlsein sie
fühlen sich krank aber lange nicht krank
genug um einen Doktor aufzusuchen oder
gar mit ihrem baldigen Ableben zu
rechnen sie sind ständig durstig leiden
gleichzeitig an Appetitlosigkeit und
depressiver Verstimmung weder der
Appetit noch die Lust am Leben werden je
zurückkehren die Männer zehren ab
verfallenen Kraftlosigkeit und Apathie
und sterben schließlich also wenn ich
das höre habe ich einen Verdacht dass
wir nämlich diese sogenannte
männergrippe ja über die sich alle
lustig machen weil wir so wehleidig sind
das ist wahrscheinlich eine Urangst ja
vor dieser bösartigen Molche leider
damals nach Rom aber Spaß beiseite wir
müssen hier noch einen Disclaimer
einfügen wenn wir diese Geschichte
gemeinsam erzählen das ist nämlich sehr
schwer bei dieser ganzen Geschichte die
Fakten klar zu kriegen und zu trennen es
gibt einfach sehr viele unterschiedliche
Versionen von dieser Geschichte zum
Beispiel gibt es Berichte nach denen das
Gift nur einmal verabreicht werden
musste anderen zufolge musste es über
einen längeren Zeitraum ins Essen
gemischt werden oder die Wirkung meist
wird eine lange Auszählung ohne krasses
Symptome beschrieben manchmal ist aber
auch von starken Magenkrämpfen Erbrechen
und Durchfall die Rede
wir halten uns an die plausibelste oder
am besten belegte Version der Geschichte
die seltsame ausziehende Krankheit
fordert unter der Oberschicht der
männlichen Oberschicht mehr Tote als die
Pest eine Zeit lang ihr reichste ist und
mächtigstes Opfer ist der Herzog
Francesco chesi sein Vater war übrigens
ein hoch angesehener Wissenschaftler und
ein Kumpel von Galileo Galilei Francesco
ist im Jahr 1657 um die 50 Jahre alt
seine Ehefrau Aldo brandini ist viel
jünger als sie geheiratet haben war sie
gerade einmal 13 Jahre alt jetzt ist sie
22 also wenn ich sowas höre mir
gewundert mich das nicht so richtig dass
dieses aquatopana damals so beliebt war
ich meine stell dir das vor mit 13 an
irgendeinen alten Sack verheiratet
werden echt krasser das ist nur ein
schwacher Trost dass ein großer Macker
mit viel Geld ist mal salopp gesagt und
das sein Vater mit Galileo verkehrt hat
kann man sagen letztendlich waren die
sicherlich einfach nur zusammen saufen
Entschuldigung ja und wenn man dann noch
weiß dass die einzige Chance aus dieser
Ehe rauszukommen der Tod ist Aldo
brandini scheint ein flotter Feger
gewesen zu sein so viel steht mal fest
von anderen römischen Damen wird sie so
beschrieben jung und schön von vielen
Worben ihre Schönheit ist nur leicht von
Pocken Narben getrübt Brocken haben
kleine Abschweifung das mit dem
pockennamen ist nämlich ganz interessant
die Pocken waren der zweite große Killer
in dieser Zeit aber der Fall liegt ein
bisschen anders als bei der Pest die
kommt und geht manchmal für Jahrhunderte
und taucht dann wieder auf und taucht
wieder nicht auf die Pocken die sind
endemisch die waren immer da in dieser
Zeit fast alle Kinder damals erkranken
daran viele sterben die die es überleben
sind in Zukunft immun aber eben auch
fürs Leben gezeichnet Pocken Narben im
Gesicht sind nicht die Ausnahme sondern
die Regel
jedenfalls ist ihre Schönheit nur leicht
von pocknarben getrübt ein großes
Kompliment für aldubrandini die junge
Frau die an der Seite ihres 30 Jahre
älteren Ehemanns versauert und Achtung
die sich schließlich verliebt also
diesmal in echt in einen Grafen namens
Francesco maria santinelli santinelli
ist 30 Jahre alt also schon mal die
gleiche Preisklasse bekannt für sein
hervorragendes Aussehen seine
Beschäftigung mit der Alchemie und seine
zahlreichen Liebschaften ja klingt jetzt
ziemlich wichtig aber der windige
Lebemann scheint es mit Aldo brandini
Ernst zu meinenen er schreibt ihr
zahllose Liebesgedichte
wie romantisch naja andererseits ist er
ja auch als Dichter bekannt er macht das
also quasi ja auch beruflich macht da
gerade nur seinen Job aber wir wollen
hier sein künstlerisches Können
natürlich nicht schmälern
jedenfalls hat das gut funktioniert
definitiv aldubrandini ist hin und weg
nur leider kann sie definitiv nicht weg
von ihrem Typen es sei denn sie hilft
ein bisschen nach also
herzoginaldobrandini kennt einen
Priester dem sie vertraut und der ihr
vielleicht helfen kann sie hat von
diesem Wundermittel gehört und
vielleicht kann Partner die Roland
helfen ist zu besorgen kann er
kontaktiert eine Frau namens Giovanna
der Grandis von der er weiß dass sie das
Gift verkauft er erhält eine schicke
Glasflasche auf der einen kunstvoll
gearbeitet des Heiligenbild Brandt das
Gift wird als Manna des heiligen
Nikolaus getarnt angeblich ein Öl das
direkt vom Grab des Heiligen stammen und
bei Akne Wunder wirken soll ein hübsches
fleischchen das keinen Verdacht erregt
und vor genauer Untersuchung sicher ist
denn solche heiligen heilmittel sind
damals weit verbreitet der Priester gibt
die Flasche einer vertrauenswürdigen
Dienerin der Herzogin weiter und
innerhalb von ein oder zwei Tagen ist
der Herzog Tod ja das ging nun etwas
schneller als diese langsame Ausziehung
von der wir vorhin gesprochen haben die
junge und schrecklich verliebte Frau
muss es wohl sehr eilig mit der
Witwenschaft gehabt haben es gibt
Berichte nach denen sie ihrem Mann
gleich die ganze Flasche ins Essen
gekippt hat bloß gut dass das Zeugs
Geschmacks und geruchsneutral war sie
wollte offenbar auf Nummer sicher gehen
was uns zu der Frage bringt was
aquatophaner eigentlich genau war
offensichtlich keins wie ein Kali denn
das riecht nach Bittermandeln so ganz
sicher ist sich die Geschichtsschreibung
nicht einige Quellen vermuten dass das
Gift ein Gemisch aus Opium und
spanischer Fliege gewesen sei die
Spanische Fliege ich glaube du du das
nie brauchtest kennst du halt
Potenzmittel nicht genauso wenig wie ich
ja aber es gilt als das viagra der
Renaissance die Spanische Fliege ist
nämlich eigentlich ein Käfer der etwa
ein bis zwei Zentimeter lang wird was
jetzt aus männlicher sich natürlich
nicht so lang ist ja mit metallisch grün
schimmert und tatsächlich im ganzen
Mittelmeerraum verbreitet ist das
Potenzmittel wurde also tatsächlich aus
zermahlenen Käfern hergestellt nicht
besonders sexy finde ich und noch
weniger sexy die vermeintliche
Potenzsteigerung kommt wenn überhaupt
durch eine massive Reizung der Harnwege
des Mannes zustande das kann zwar zu
einer Erektion führen sogar zu einer
äußerst schmerzhaften Dauererektion aber
ich sag mal ja der Spaß ist dann
sicherlich damit dahin
wir sind jetzt irgendwie auf Abwege
geraten ich versuche jetzt mal also ganz
hart wieder aufs Thema zurückzukommen
die Spanische Fliege ist als Bestandteil
ja nicht unplausibel da ist bei der
Überdosierung sehr wohl zum Tot
kann andere Theorien über das Gift die
sind da schon wesentlich unglaubwürdiger
muss man sagen genau zum Beispiel die
Geschichte mit der Spucke bzw dem Geifer
von Menschen die zu Tode gefoltert oder
an den Beinen aufgehängt und gekitzelt
worden du erinnerst dich wie könnte ich
nicht also du kommst jetzt mit deiner
mozart-story um die Ecke oder wie ja
aber auf Mozart komme ich später noch
mal zurück die gängigste Erklärung ist
jedenfalls das Arsen der
Hauptbestandteil des aquatophaner war
also hier wird vielleicht nie wirklich
Klarheit herrschen da die Symptome eine
Arsenvergiftung eigentlich nicht zu
diesem viel beschriebenen schleichenden
Verlauf passen da gibt es nämlich
Krämpfe Übelkeit innere Blutung
Durchfall und wirklich andere schwer zu
übersehende vergiftungsanzeichen aber
was auch immer nur im aquathophaner
enthalten ist bei Francesco cheesy
wirkte sie jedenfalls sein schneller Tod
verwundert viele doch der jungen Witwe
will niemand die Schuld geben aber
leider wird auch nichts aus den Träumen
von der großen Liebe mit ihrem dichten
den Schönling stattdessen wurde sie
eingesperrt aber Achtung nicht als
Mörderin die eigene Familie hat sie
weggeschlossen um zu verhindern dass sie
sich in eine skandalöse zweite Ehe mit
ihrem windigen geliebten stürzt das ist
wirklich krass Leute oder sie war eine
Mörderin okay insofern hätte man sagen
können das war eine Art höhere
Gerechtigkeit aber das hat natürlich mit
Gerechtigkeit überhaupt nichts zu tun
erst verschachern sie ihre Tochter mit
13 Jahren an einen alten Knacker und
kaum schnuppert sie kurz die Freiheit da
sperren sie sich schon wieder ein damit
sie um Gottes Willen der Familie keine
Schande macht oh mann oh mann oh mann ja
ja wirklich üble Zeiten und auch wenn
wir hier wirklich keine Morde
entschuldigen wollen ist es doch immer
wichtig auch nach dem Warum zu fragen
statt die Täter und eben auch mal
Täterinnen sofort als Monster
abzustempeln im Jahr nach dem Mord an
Herzog Francesco tesi fliegt Monate
grandis letztendlich auf wie das
folgende ganz genau ablief ist unklar
wie so einiges an dieser faszinierende
Geschichte weil es da mehrere sich
widersprechende Versionen gibt wir
erzählen die Variante die uns am
wahrscheinlichsten erscheint und die
sich auf Chroniken und Gerichtsakten der
damaligen Zeit bezieht Mirko Giovanna de
grandis wird verhaftet und hat ein
Fläschchen von dem Gift bei sich sie
behauptet natürlich dass sei nur ein
Mittel gegen Akne aber die Behörden
glauben mir nicht da ist diese Flut ein
mysteriösen Todesfällen und Jungen
Witwen der Papst drängt so schnellen
Aufklärung und endlich können Sie einen
Erfolg verbuchen doch es ist klar dass
Jovana nicht allein gehandelt hat um
auch wirklich alle Beteiligten zu
schnappen stellen sie ihr eine Falle
Giovanna wird wieder freigelassen und
eine florentinische Adlige Namen seniora
loretti wird als Lockvogel in die Stadt
gebracht und erzählt unter der falschen
Identität einer matchesa romanini
überall von ihrer unglücklichen Ehe sie
bietet eine große Summe für ein
Fläschchen aquatufana mit ihrer Hilfe
und der Mitwirkung der die grandis die
sich Straffreiheit erhofft wird kurz
darauf eine ganze Bande von
giftmischerinnen verhaftet und vor
Gericht gestellt mehr als 600 Männer
sollen ihnen im Laufe der Jahre zum
Opfer gefallen sein
600 das ist glaube ich bei einer Rekord
für diesen Podcast oder naja da war die
Blutgräfin die hatten wir hier auch
schon die kommt nach manchen Berichten
ja auf einen mir sei das erlaubt mal zu
sagen auf einen selben Leute die count
ja die Täterinnen werden zum Tode
verurteilt auch Giovanna die grandis
ihre Kooperation mit den Behörden hat er
nichts genutzt am 6 juli 1659 wird sie
zusammen mit mindestens vier weiteren
Beteiligten in Anwesenheit einer
ungewöhnlich großen Menschenmenge
gehängt
das klingt nach dem Ende der Geschichte
dabei haben wir die beiden Hauptpersonen
noch gar nicht erwähnt also wird es
langsam Zeit dafür ihren Namen sollten
euch allerdings schon vertraut vorkommen
wir sprechen nämlich von Giulia tophana
und theophania die Adamo aquatophana
oder der theophania die ganze Sache ist
ein bisschen verworren und es gibt wie
so oft bei dieser Geschichte mehrere
Versionen meist wird die Geschichte so
erzählt theophania Adamo sei die
Erfinderin des aquatopaner gewesen
zusammen mit einer Komplizin habe sie
das Gift in Palermo auf Sizilien
verkauft sei aber gefasst und zusammen
mit ihrer Verbündeten 1633 hingerichtet
worden Julia Tofana sei wiederum ihre
Tochter gewesen das klingt erstmal nicht
unplausibel denn es war damals in
Sizilien durchaus üblich dass Töchter
den Vornamen ihrer Mutter als Nachnamen
Annahmen vermutlich ist das aber ein
Mythos der erst im 19 Jahrhundert
entstand Julia tofanas richtiger Name
scheint Julia mangiardi gewesen zu sein
sie war wohl eher eine Schülerin der
theophania um 1624 kommt Julia mangiardi
bzw Tofana nach Rom und zwar in
Begleitung einer wesentlich jüngeren
Frau sie selbst ist da schon Mitte 40
die jüngere Frau ist ihre Stieftochter
die olama Barbara den Namen hatten wir
schon Giro Lamas Barbara
1659 wird sie als Chefin der Bande von
Giftmischer Rennen hingerichtet die
beiden Frauen sind so wird vermutet nach
einem fehlgeschlagenen giftattentat aus
Palermo geflohen um den Ermittlungen zu
entgehen über die Zeit zwischen 1624 und
den 50er Jahren ist wenig bekannt wir
wissen nicht wann Tofana und Bader
wieder mit der giftmischerei begannen
aber wahrscheinlich wird die Bande wohl
um das Jahr 1650 gegründet und zu ihren
Aktivitäten gehört anscheinend nicht nur
die Bereitstellung des Giftes sondern
auch die Akquise von Kunden durch eine
Art Eheberatung die nämlich geplagten
Ehefrauen die Entscheidung leicht machen
soll also eine Art rund um Service aber
weiter wo war Julia Tofana als die Bande
1659 aufflog hier haben wir wieder
verschiedene Versionen die langweiligste
ist wohl auch die wahrscheinlichste das
heißt sie sei schon um 1651 herum
gestorben
ganz friedlich im eigenen Bett immerhin
war sie da auch schon 70 das klingt also
auch irgendwie plausibel wer ist
dramatischer mag kann sich an andere
Quellen halten danach sei sie in ein
Kloster geflohen als die Bande auflog
das Kloster sei von einer wütenden
Menschenmenge belagert worden bis man
sie schließlich über die Mauer die
wütenden Mob zum Fraß vorgeworfen habe
eindeutig die bessere Version finde ich
ja oder man habe sie geschnappt ein
Geständnis aus ihr herausgefordert und
sie dann erwirkt oder ihr bei lebendigem
Leibe die Glieder herausgerissen Mirko
oder sie habe noch 1730 in einem Kaka
gelebt
1731 hätte sie dann dort ihren 150
Geburtstag feiern können auch nicht
schlecht naja ihr seht schon da
verlassen die endgültig die Geschichte
und begeben uns ins Reich der Fantasie
apropos Mirko bevor wir ganz aufhören du
schuldest mir jetzt doch hier noch deine
Mozart Nummer meine Mutter
naja eher ein ein Mozart nimmerchen so
klein wie eine Mozartkugel aber nicht
ganz so gehaltvoll also auch Mozart soll
durch aquatophaner gestorben sein halt
Mirko ich weiß da steckt doch bestimmt
dieser Salieri dahinter sein großer
finsterer Gegenspieler ja das könnte man
meinen nur dass dieser ganze beef
zwischen Mozart und Salieri wohl eher
einer Erfindung ist und der einzige
Hinweis auf die Vergiftung stammt von
Mozart selbst als er 1791 erkrankte
schrieb er ich bin sicher dass ich
vergiftet worden bin ich werde diesen
Gedanken nicht los jemand hat mir
aquatophaner gegeben und den genauen
Zeitpunkt meines Todes berechnet also ob
er jetzt den Film neu drehen müsste ich
weiß es nicht was wir aus dieser
Geschichte auf jeden Fall lernen ist wie
stark der Mythos des aquatophaner
nachwirkte und wie lange er Menschen und
man muss sagen vor allem uns Männer in
Angst und Schrecken versetzte das war
also eine ganz schöne Geschichte
unintelligible und sie lässt einen ein
bisschen sprachlos zurück oder Mirko auf
jeden Fall und damit sind wir für heute
am Ende der Episode angelangt schön dass
ihr dabei wart wir hoffen es hat euch
gefallen und wir freuen uns wenn ihr
auch beim nächsten Mal dabei seid bei
Tatort Deutschland wir haben uns für
diese Episode durch einen ganzen Berg
von sich zum Teil widersprechenden
Artikeln und Quellen gewühlt die
wichtigste und wohl vertrauenswürdigste
war der sehr umfangreiche und sehr gut
belegte Beitrag aquatopaner slow
poiseling an husband killing in
seventies century Italy auf Mike Dash
history.com und wer aufgepasst hat
natürlich verdanken wir auch der
spanischen Flieger eine gewisse
Mitwirkung an diesem Podcast wir danken
euch fürs zuhören und freuen uns wenn
ihr auch beim nächsten Mal dabei seid
euer Mirko und euer Stefan Schnitt Toni
heuer Postproduktion durch die weight
watch Studios München